[Music]
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the war we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from who believed in you and who did it
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
I'm appalled
the Lara
they evolve an egg-white life
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
[Music]
can you describe it for know start from
the beginning what do you think I do
when you're away you think I'm out in
the garden pining looking at the sky I
gotta leave a day early
[Music]
your husband's here let me see him he's
extremely ill you have to tell me why
why is what he was doing it was his
decision to go in
it's something they termed the shimmer
we've sent in drones and teams of people
but nothing comes back but something has
you're a biologist who served in the
military if I knew what happened
I could save his life the boundary is
getting bigger it's expanding we're
talking cities States you need to know
what's inside it's beautiful
check this out it's like they're stuck
in a continuous rotation are they
understand they're no sharks have teeth
like that not possible you can't cross
great different species yes
well soldiers on the last expedition eat
like crazy or something in here kill
them something's come to the face or the
fence we have to go back I can't go back
we can camp here tonight
it's destroying everything it's not
destroyed
it's making something new generous
honest pure graceful creatures our
natural rabbit space to be able to be
[Applause]
sure what that would never have worked
no pants you must be Peter Rabbit that's
right wait did you try to eat me
show me your teeth do you like a go bug
it was how are you so good to see you
[Music]
hello
[Music]
new neighbor I'll explain it to him
we'll share our land around here hello
I'm B these gates are incredibly sturdy
I just need to keep the wildlife out
where they belong you're right there are
angels this is their place okay so he's
tricked up there's only one way out of
this he's gotta go face was so classic I
have a vermin problem an electric fence
or paper now no this is the wincle stop
look away we can't give up it's our only
success
[Music]
you're mine ribbit
[Applause]
[Music]
wait two boys getting along nothing
could make me happier I got us into this
we're gonna fix it tonight we're taking
game night up a notch oh boy
someone in this room is going to be
taken and it's gonna be up to you to
find them it's a murder mystery party
whoever finds the victim wins the grand
prize you're not gonna know what's real
and what's fake wait a sec you can't
just come in here and break the door ho
guys make sure you get a piece of this
cheese okay Roger that
you drive safe I've always enjoyed the
camaraderie of good friends competing in
games of chance and skill to revalue it
seems like Ryan you go first I'm scared
[Music]
it's not a joke people are in real
danger is God real Oh
oh so much worse
stop wait me I have kids at home not
with an ass like yet you don't oh well
thank you
oh no he died his instructions on how to
remove the bullets didn't have rubbing
alcohol so I got you this lovely sharp
good idea way to pivot and then a
squeaky toy for the pain its gargantuan
seven storage structure with no apparent
rhyme or reason
each maze of halls more confusing than
the next it's under never-ending
construction
it was built on the orders of a grieving
widow
Sarah Winchester is the majority
shareholder of the Winchester Repeating
Arms Company who want to take it away
from her worried about her sanity dr.
price do you believe in ghosts
stop - I do not believe in anything I
cannot see or study
[Music]
[Music]
I can feel it in the air in the walls
this spirit has a power we've not seen
before it has found us dear Aunt Lucy
you sent me to London to find a home I
have a wonderful family I think you're
in great shape for a man your age mr.
Brown Wow Thank You Paddington hang on
how old do you think I am Oh about 80
and I've really got to grips with how
things work Mr Gruber I mean I'd like to
get my Aunt Lucy a birthday present how
about these Ruling shoes please Mr
Gruber be serious what's this
this puppy book is the only one of its
kind and they want a lot of money for it
I'm going to get a job and buy that book
no window cleaner
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
cheerio but if you cover hold it right
there oh but I'm not the thief we're
rich again round Hey
laundry duty it's only one red sock
what's the worst that can happen
afternoon chaps I want to hear all about
the investigation Paddington is innocent
he's a master of disguise well this is
breaking and entering haven't broken
anything
[Applause]
you think you're going there
[Music]
Paddington looks for the good in all of
us and somehow he finds it if we're kind
and polite the world will be right
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Molly bloom do you know about me
this is a true story
you ran a games in LA for roughly eight
years yeah then you ran a games in New
York for roughly two I don't run a game
in over two years not to spoil the
ending but that's when the government
raided my game and took all of my money
assuming all of it was made illegally
which it wasn't in this room you
couldn't buy your win from Allah you
couldn't buy me then you couldn't buy a
seat at the table we saw it athletes
written as that's just the tip of the
iceberg you're not taking a percentage
of the pot no keep it that way because
you don't break the law when you're
breaking the law
am I breaking the law we're able to find
out for sure
aren't we flaws are written down the
admin is anyway about your book in life
right I did you spent eight years
funding the world's most exclusive
glamorous and decadent mancave for the
office guarantee the publisher has
certain elements that I can get you a
million and a half what kind of elements
I passed I'm just curious as to why you
pass on what would appear to be the only
way out you have these real names
creative differences
the love that I'm accused of breaking
the plans gambling is betting on games
of chance yes
pokers in a game of chance pokers a game
of skill
why does a young woman at 22 as a
gold-plated resume
why does she run her games your risk is
nuts you're gonna get blown up
you got 2.8 million on the street right
now if that money should be in your
hands just how deep into the Russian mob
were you
is a new offer on the table completely
we hand over Audra you see what's on
those hard drives family's lives careers
will be ruling why are you in this alone
where are the people you're protected by
not telling the whole story it's not
their names I'm protecting charlie my
because it's night mate
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider abnormally
yes less question do you know a mutants
are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why your year
[Music]
what is this place this is in the
hospital what's a haunted house
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hard get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
one trip
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
they stay because of all the things they
can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning
find him just a game
I'm talking about two life-and-death
stuff the Oasis
the world's most important economic
resource it's nothing less than a war
for control of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came in to escape but I found
something much bigger than just myself
are you willing to fight
[Music]
helped us save the oasis
[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and learn all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty 2 inch brush here
work that off a little bit just feel
like it owes you money we're gonna get a
little dab or yellow snow here mix that
with just another little dab of our baby
water now well that's just Daniel Sedin
have a little say I remember this is
your world you get to make and break the
rules here sweet baby Jesus we're
shopping jump in there and roll around
and all that cascading white powder yeah
just get high and all of life's splendor
God I love cocaine so much holy [ __ ]
knuckles I am high as a kite right now
ok let's paint in a few little happy
trees there nothing wrong with making
friends with trees no what you don't
want to do is eat these paints trust me
on this one
alright I'm gonna walk off from Ken
that's right that feels good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
not drugs
[Music]
you